kylie ann e faucheux 14 ans n'est pas un
adolescent comme les autres ce collégien
de 3e est actuellement considéré comme
le futur prodige dhuys portes en france
du sport via les jeux vidéo sa
spécialité le football le jeune marque
des buts avec sa touche carré déplace
ses joueurs et que son joli stick depuis
ses 6 ans quand j'étais petit mon père
un petit peu au jeu vidéo avant a ajouté
ce témoin forme qui perdait souvent et
après je me sens très à l'aise
entraîneur entraîné un jour un peu en
ligne et du coup l envie de jouer aux
jeux vidéo change de foot
après avoir emporté des centaines de
matchs en ligne qu'ils viennent alias
kills ou s'est fait un nom plutôt un
pseudo dans le milieu en 2015 il a
intégré la néo esport 95 une équipe
d'une quinzaine d'adeptes composés sont
les spécialistes des meilleurs joueurs
du monde sur les jeux de football fifa
et pes c'est mieux pour beaucoup de
choses pour moi c'est l'esprit d'équipé
il ya les tournois qui se font aussi en
équipe il ya toujours du président où
n'importe qui peut te dépanner pour
quelque chose s'est amené en tournoi on
part en plus à plusieurs c'est toujours
mieux partir tout seul à cinq heures de
route
une alchimie qui fonctionne qui viennent
a remporté des dizaines de tournois dont
celui de la paris games week
des performances qui lui ont permis
d'empocher près de 1500 euros cette
année
mais pour continuer à progresser le
sportif virtuel s'entraînent une heure
tous les jours une passion encouragé par
sa mère sous certaines conditions
je te pousse à continuer
mais comme tous les parents à condition
que qu'il soit sérieux au niveau de ces
notes et de ses études un entraînement
nécessaires pour accomplir son plus
grand rêve devenir le meilleur joueur du
monde du x porte dans les prochaines
années